now you've posted pictures online and it
baby think was bringing your children
back there that wise like you Pitt was
this but like that's your help
yeah that is uh that's a yeah one of the
bedrooms here is it one of the
children's bedrooms occasionally yeah
yeah not since that snake lives there
and then you pick ones this one as well
like is that in your house it is yeah
yeah they better than paparazzi though
those animals look okay no more thoughts
you know I would take paparazzi over
this writer and the snake yeah you know
that snake the what you don't say we'd
had a couple of drinks that night when
we discovered that snake in the bedroom
and I love Australia I know was very sir
we've had a few drinks when we found the
snake and it was a Friday satellite and
I'm Ross generally gone what is it and
someone's like it's a brown snake which
can kill you you know very quickly
someone's like now it's a tree python
it's something else is this and I just
launched into like action mode grab it
by the tail picked it up anyone starts
freaking out and it starts to kind of
coil itself back up toward me which is
getting ready to strike and I'm
everything at what the hell am i doing
so I just kind of threw this night back
into the bedroom then shut the door we
don't go in that bedroom anymore I
boarded up thing up we have a little
mobile with stars and Suns on it which
is yeah
because now justice I said you are a
lover of the Australian wildlife because
this yes I am notice what this picture
taken in Australia you with the kangaroo
no you take in New York oh so that was a
New York hanger it's a traveling banger
yes not a baby kangaroo that is a baby
kangaroo but what makes me slightly
disappointed is it's totally upstaging
me on that cover in fairness it is I
mean model face it is given like kazooie
bucks look pretty cool I'm guessing the
kangaroo was quite squirmy yeah I mean
they're very hoppy
yeah and technical too yeah and you know
likes to play likes to hop around but
was very very happy whenever I had the
bottle because they would do anything
for the bulk I feel you'd had enough of
the Hobby because there's a picture
inside the magazine of you with the
kangaroo sad because it looks like I'm
just like love me thank you so much and
it's just like give me the food they
could at least Photoshop the bottle out
right that wouldn't look weirder rabies
is no guess big animal lover Kirsten
Dunst as well but not cats you've
already mentioned a cat cats are your
first love well I like yeah I do like
cats
I don't know about my first love but
yeah okay and you just got a new cat
well that cat adopted me oh I see so
yeah yeah G you yeah yeah like did it
wander in yeah I just wandered in
started feeding and now he sleeps in bed
with me every night so he just yeah he's
just like my cat yeah it is weird you
would never do that with a person we
like specific to animals
what's the name of the cat Tito I
thought it was a boy for the longest I
severe it'll usually those orange stripy
cats or boys I don't know why I know
this but um but then my friend came over
was like there those balls are very
small I don't think that's a boy there
isn't a small bowl
it was like okay if it's a he/she
whatever it is all I don't care I'll
still Tito's a fine name for it and so
yeah it's a boy but I think this is a
picture if you don't you can tell Tina
was such a boy look at that that is a
boy look at the man spread on that right
it's got a third leg daddy a boy that is
a very tricky Ricky wants a hug
really yeah he wants beer and some chick
is that race it's all the time now let's
see it's just mid lick
oh those tiny bowls he was just to
making them clean yeah they're small but
they're really clean
why don't you be embarrassed
lots of hairy men standing around
watching you that's why I imagine what
doggin feels like